hello everyone welcome back to the
capablanca saga and we are back to the
1911 sense a bastion tournament where
this is round 4 kappa blanka has two
wins and the draw against Frank James
Marshall here he faces none other than
dr. Ziegler to Irish now zebra Tosh was
one of the strongest players in the
world as we already mentioned but not
only that his actual profession was well
he was a doctor he finished medical
school and he had his own medical
practice where he of course practiced
medicine and that often interfered with
his chest life and I guess it's a bit
weird to say interfered as okay saving
lives of is more important than playing
chess but well it often did for example
in 1892 he had the opportunity to face
will Hammerstein it's for the title but
he passed he rejected the offer as he
had well other work to do a medical wise
and in those days for example in
tournaments out of the four times he
faced Steinitz he beat him three times
and one time they drew so the odds were
definitely in his favor and later he
when last we became world champion he
Alaska always had better results against
other opponents in tournaments and
finally when Ziegler tarush got his
opportunity to face loss score in 1908
Alaska beat him you know with with quite
a score I believe it was 8 to 3 or
something like that but definitely a
convincing result but yeah definitely a
strong player and here he has the white
pieces against Jose woke up a blank and
it's cappas first time facing this great
player so let's see how it goes and yes
by this point kaapa does know some
opening theory for those of you who are
wondering so let's check it out we have
E 4 by Tara she 5 we have Knight to f3
be tonight the c6 and birch of the c4
and yeah it's an Italian game tariff was
very much known for his skills in the
opening and well middle game in and game
but he contributed a lot to theory for
example you all know the tower defense
the
Queens gambit you know the tariff line
of the French defense a lot of
interesting ideas bear the name of
Taurus so okay Bishop to c5 and here
unfortunately we do not have the Evans
gambit but okay c3 the Joko piano
we have Knight to f6 d4 we have a
captures on d4 seek after some d4 and
Bishop to b4 check and here Bishop to d2
by Irish for those of you who are
perhaps new to chess one of the more
exciting attacks in chess in general is
the Greco attack which can happen if
white goes for Knight to c3 and it's of
course it will not work against someone
like a Blanca but against weaker players
you can always try it or if you're just
starting out - feel free to try the
Greco attack on your own it's an idea
you you block check but you also give up
d4 pawn and after Knight captures you
can just Castle and here while black has
a variety of ways to continue this game
in the olden days when weaker players
two faced masters often the games would
go like Knight captures on c3 be
captures and rush of captures here white
would go Queen b3 offered the rook and
after black captured the rook wife would
finish the game with a very nice attack
after Bishop captures on f7 King f8
Bishop g8 now forcing the Knights to
block the attack against the Queen the
Queen has nowhere to go after Knight
blocks rook e1 and it's all over there's
no way to prevent the Bishop captures on
e7 whatever whatever you play but
captures captures captures captures and
now well pretty much anything will win
for white but that that is a 1/1 way a
Grieco attack can happen but here bishop
to d2 instead we have Bishop captures by
Capablanca Knight captures and now comes
d5 d6 would be a bit too slow so a
couple of Lanka uses the this Bishop and
pawn at bust
White's Center and you know speed up his
development he captures on d5 we have
Knight captures on d5 and now Queen to
b3 with a double attack against the
knight on d5 also the knight cannot move
as the pawn on f7 would fall so we have
a knight C 2 e 7
defending the night now with the night
Queen and also c6 is coming fairly soon
we have castles by tarush castles by
Capablanca and now troop F 2 e1
developing the rook we have c6 now
giving further control to the d5 square
and now a for grabbing space on the
Queen side also preventing b5 we have
Queen to b6 kappa blanka offers a queen
trade and now comes the Queen to a3
capablanca has to be careful now if he
plays something like Bishop to g4 then
of course you also the threat after
Queen a3 rook captures an a on e7 and
white would happily give up the look for
for two nights so of course after this
Queen to a to remove capablanca simply
block the Roca Bishop to e6 a nice
developing move and here we have a 5 and
as the story goes here parish went into
a into a deep think as he wasn't really
sure how to continue this game even
though this was still considered opening
theory at the time for example even in
1898 McCutcheon played against collector
here and the Knights the e4 was the move
here but that game ended in a draw but
here after a 5 we have a new game
between the two gentlemen the Queen has
to go back we have Queen to c7 and now
comes Knight to e4 and excellent square
for the knight and now rook a to d8 a
couple Blanca introduces the Queen side
rook into the game night the c5
now again an excellent square for the
knight it's a bit nah it's not all that
great to try and kick it out with b6 and
the bishop on e6 is under attack so
kappa blanka brings it back we have
Bishop to c8 also the bishop is now
giving further control to the Queen side
and now comes g3 taking away DF 4 square
from kappa blanka night and also
inviting Capablanca to maybe go Bishop
to h3 and while this is a possibility
white really wants to play a 6 here and
then either exchange everything and
leave black with a week a 7 pawn or if
black decides to put upon let's say b5
then the after Bishop moves then the c6
bond becomes a week where wife can
always play rook the c1 perhaps even
double rooks on the C file and go after
this c6 weakness a weakness of a pawn
so after g3 we have Knight to f5 we have
rook a to d1 now developing the other
night is the other look as well as the
d4 pawn is somewhat pressured and now
nice the d6 attacking the bishop and
here kappa blanka Fator decides to
capture on d5 Bishop captures on d5 and
now comes not see captures but first
nice to b5 attacking the Queen and
opening up a discovered attack from the
roof to the bishop Queen to b4 and only
now rook captures on d5 and now Knight
to b3 now both of the Knights are
controlling the e5 square and you really
want to take take a hold of that square
Bishop to g4 now again developing this
bishop and now comes the night D to e5
an excellent square for the knight and
also your defending the knight on f3 and
here we have h5 defending the bishop on
g4 we have Knight captures on g4 h
captures on g4 forcing this night to
move and now comes nice to h4 and rook F
to d8 so as you can see now kappa blanka
force the tarush knife to h4 and he has
this excellent attack against the d4
pawn the night the rook and the other
rook are all attacking this pawn on d4 I
even used a green square here to really
point it out
and now we have rook to e7 any slow move
here as there's really no good way to
defend it you have to you have to play
actively so rook to e7 attacking cover
Blancas Queen we have Queen to d6
offering the Queen trade and now Queen
captures on d6 Knight captures on d6 the
knight from d6 also protects the b7 pawn
and now what
Tariq wanted to play all along a six he
wants to create a week a seven point but
also if black decides to pull it upon
then the c6 bone becomes a week as well
kappa blanka captures we have b captures
on a6 rook captures an a7 and now comes
nights to b5 attacking
rook ended the d4 pawn captures an a6
and now Knight captures on d4 grabbing
the pawn here and also keeping an eye on
the c6 pawn but also preparing a lot of
nasty threats here for example if this
night was to be developed let's say if
tarush were to introduce it into the
game via knife to g2 then black could
immediately go Knight f3 check and then
black wins as the rookin d1 is unguarded
but star says no way Jose and he was
king to f1 not allowing Knight to f3 to
come with the check so g5 forcing the
knight back we have nice - g2 and now as
the knight is no longer controlling the
f3 square we have Knight to f3 so you do
have to do something about this threat
here rook captures on d5 is played C
captures on d5 not allowing the pawn to
stay a target and now we have nights to
e1 offering a trade here and it's a
sneaky move so if you look at this
position kappa blanka has a past D pawn
where a star has a past beep on and
tarish spawn is a much further from
Kappa Blancas king then kappa blanka
spawn is from Terrence King so white
white could even be better here but
tarnish is also by playing this nice
that you want to move is basically
offering a draw as he's offering couple
longer to capture on h2 and that's a
well calculated to draw for for example
if couple longer captures knife captures
on h2 with the Czech King do too
then you can push the d4 pawn let's say
D for a temporary Knight sacrifice King
captures d3 now Knight the G - D - and
now nice to e3 guarding the d1 square
you can push it let's say you bring a
queen Knight captures rook captures and
now comes Luke to a5 attacking the g5
pawn here f6 defending and now a for
attacking the pawn here rogue d2
attacking both the f1 and the b-pawn
after the King defense now you will
capture this pawn white captures this
pawn and now it's 2 rooks 2 points each
you know the pond the pawn setup is a
well pretty symmetrical so it would be a
dead draw and tarish knows this that's
why he played nights the e1 but a couple
banker declines it he is not ready to
just to call it a draw just yet
we have rook to e8 now again or
threatening rook captures and rook to g1
checkmate
Tyrus plays nice captures on f3 we have
G captures on f3 now kappa blanka
fixes his pawn structure also the point
is very nicely controlling the e2 and
the g2 squares here we have looked the
d6 by tarish of course you have to put a
room behind the past pawn that's how
that's how chess works and kappa blanka
place rooks are up to c8
now of course if tarnish would over
would capture on d5 then capablanca
could deliver rook to see one check
after the roadblocks then this would be
checkmate as we already mentioned the
pawn is controlling e 2 and G 2 but - of
course we'll not for for a foreign force
fall for something like this
Kingston 1 was played and here rook to
e8 check by capablanca kinked back to f1
and here look back to see it by
Capablanca and it was in this position
that these two great players agreed to a
draw as if you decided to continue it
wouldn't really change anything for
example if you continue to this line of
King he one rookie check and now you
actually played the King to d1 then even
after something like rook to e2 you
don't want to allow black such activity
but it would still be a draw after rook
captures rook captures rook captures
here with check King to f8 and now after
we start pushing her past pawn rook
captain's on h2 threatening the Queen
the F pawn soon but then King defense
and now capablanca has well his past
point is further down the board but
still I mean it's a double death pawn
and it's a completely drawn endgame so
after Luke to see it they decided that
this was a draw and it indeed was a draw
so after four games in the tooth in the
1911 system of San Sebastian tournament
Capablanca is now two draws and to two
wins so still without a loss and he's
doing pretty great against such such
very strong players so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it we're
gonna be covering Game five of this
tournament
fairly soon I would like to thank
Tristan Cummings we toured the Great Sea
Ramgopal Kota Adam miss Suzuki and Alex
Riddick for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
and for those of you who weren't
following my other social networks I
will put a link in the description below
it will be the first thing you see a
certain gentleman created a let's say a
best moments video of my channel so if
you enjoy this channel I mean I do click
on the first link in the description
below and you know it's a it's really a
very very nice video you know excellent
editing and really a nice compilation of
great moments throughout the years so as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content thank you all
and I'll see you soon